let's look at this further with Peter
Saunders who's head of the UK's National
Association for people abused in
childhood
welcome to DW do you think it's fair to
say these latest revelations this time
from Germany fit a global pattern
good evening feel they they absolutely
do I mean I've been working with victims
and survivors and I am one myself for
over 20 years so none of these
revelations are actually new what is
horrible is is to actually have to
confront the reality that as
institutions go the Catholic Church
harbors in reality more criminals than
any other institution on the planet I
mean if it we were talking about in
multinational corporation a business
that had so many rapists and perverts
dotted around the globe many in the
southern hemisphere that we don't tend
to look at very often we there would be
an absolute outcry and outrage but there
hasn't been until now and now
organizations like nae pack might own in
the UK that has the support of the
British government thank God and ending
clergy abuse the organization I'm here
in Berlin meeting with tomorrow we're
having a congress a conference in in
this wonderful city to discuss this
issue
at long last something is starting to
happen but there are no excuses Phil
that the church hasn't taken this issue
seriously in the past and done something
about it because it absolutely could now
this is a pope who many are putting
their hopes on to promote change and
until recently you were working on his
child protection a commission you were
disappointed by your experience why well
beyond disappointed when I met the Pope
in 2014 I really thought that things I
thought he was taking this massive
seriously I thought something
significant fundamental was going to
change because you know abuse in the
Catholic Church is is is a pandemic it
goes on everywhere I I've I've heard
from mostly adults who were abused as
kids of course from all over the world
and during the course of my brief period
of time on that papal Commission
absolutely nothing had happened and of
course I was ejected because I started
to voice that opinion so the church
doesn't like to air these issues it
doesn't like transparency it protects
its own and as I say it's the biggest
organization in the world I would say
that that has more I hate to use the
word pedophile because they're not all
pedophiles but child abusers more than
any other organization it's a it's an
outrageous
so stop we have on the one hand we have
the Pope's Commission and you were part
of it you'll you were looking at this
from the inside dissatisfied with with
what you you saw and and left it so it
was a public relations exercise so what
is it then did why is the church so
resistant to the idea of arresting all
these criminals within it and just
cleaning out the stables isn't what if I
can mix my metaphors I can't mix your
metaphors all you like you need to get
some of the Cardinals or the
Archbishop's sitting here and try and
explain why they do this I'd I
personally you know as a Christian I
don't understand it these are supposed
to be people of God but the way they
behave clearly they many of them there
are good priests and nuns around let's
let's let's not forget that but the
people at the top of the tree the people
who run this institution are basically
morally corrupt as far as I'm concerned
do you think then that they think they
can just ride this out because barely a
day goes by without there being another
revelation of thousands more children
having abused here there and everywhere
do you think they can just wait for this
to pass that's what they're relying on
and that's what they've got away with
for generations but at long last you and
I having a conversation about this we've
got this Congress in Berlin at the
weekend we're discussing this six more
states in the United States of America
have announced that they are doing an
investigation into the Catholic Church
within their own
dates this is you know we have the
independent inquiry in the UK that is
also looking at the Catholic Church
we've had the Royal Commission in
Australia that has strongly condemned
the Catholic Church the Church of my
upbringing things are going to change
and I don't fit and I think that last
the Pope if nobody else realizes that
they can't get away with this
criminality any any longer film
complicated question that I'm going to
ask you to try and answer briefly our
national governments complicit in this
why aren't natural governments white
national legal authorities prosecuting
more of these people well it's a good
question we could talk about it for
hours in too many parts of the world the
church has had far too much power and
far too much of a a cosy relationship
I mean Ireland being an example a place
close to where we were brought up that
is no longer the case but the church was
a dominant factor and a dominant force
in Ireland for generations at last
that's no longer the case but in many
other parts of the world it still is
feel good talking to you thank you so
much for joining us Peter Saunders from
the UK set National Association for
people abused in childhood